Throughout the many years I have been working with the house of Dior;...
...I have had the opportunity to meet many extraordinary and engaged women.
They are all driven by the same, unique spirit.
All "Chin Up" women, powerful and impactful, proud of who they are,...
...proud of what they have accomplished.
Today, I am very pleased to celebrate this feminine pride...
...by bringing together some exceptional, inspiring women.
Passionate, committed, "Chin up", no matter what.
They have all strived to have an impact on the world and...
...they have used their voices to inspire other women.
They have all joined me in passing on the sense of purpose...
...through a cause very dear to my heart, that Dior has supported for many years.
The CTAOP Youth Leaders Scholarship Program is helping...
...young South Africans to become the leaders of tomorrow.